President Trump is again promoting
congressman Ron de santis to be the
Republican nominee for governor in
Florida he sent out a new tweet today
calling DeSantis a brilliant young
leader our latest Fox News poll
indicates state agriculture commissioner
Adam Putnam is ahead of DeSantis but 39%
of voters in Florida say they are still
undecided we will have a debate between
the top two candidates live from Orlando
next Thursday night 6:30 p.m. Eastern
Time hosted by Martha McCallum
and yours truly this evening
correspondent Peter Doocy looks at how
that race in Florida is shaping up the
early frontrunner in the fight to be
Florida's Republican nominee for
governor are you Adam Putnam the
agriculture commissioner and his
platform is focused on a lot more than
crops and livestock well what we're
seeing is forces from the left come in
to Florida to hijack our politics and
it's not because they care about our
schools it's not because they care about
our business climate it's not because
they care about how much traffic there
is on the Florida Turnpike it's because
they're choosing Florida as a proxy
fight for the war on the white house in
2020 help me go the last three governors
in Florida have all been Republicans Jeb
Bush charlie Crist and Rick Scott the
state is also home to the highest
percentage of residents 65 and over in
the US they want a place where they can
retire and have government off their
back so a lot of these voters this older
generation tend to come out in when they
vote in higher numbers
congressman Ron de santis has never won
a statewide election but finds ways for
Florida voters to keep tabs on him on
Capitol Hill I am earning my paycheck I
mean I'm up here fighting you know we're
holding trying to hold the Pieterse
trucks and the commis accountable and
doing that caught president Trump's
attention he tweeted today congressman
Ron de Santos a top student at Yale and
Harvard Law School is running for
governor of the great state of Florida
Ron is strong on borders tough on crime
and big on cutting taxes loves our
military and our vets he will be a great
governor and has my full endorsement as
governor of Florida you're gonna have to
have a relationship with the White House
we have a hurricane hopefully not we
need aid I call the president directly
he's gonna take my call the Putnam
supports Trump too but doubts De Santis
can use DC connections to win this is a
florida-based race and Washington is not
going to get it done and dialing in a
gubernatorial campaign from out of state
long distance isn't going to get it done
ultimately this races result may cause a
ripple effect felt far from Tallahassee
as Florida goes so the nation goes where
a swing state where an important state
and I would like to think that we set
the policy here in the state of Florida
for the rest of nation outside of DC
Florida winds up being the backdrop for
more major political news than anywhere
else because that's where the
president's mar-a-lago estate is and his
involvement in this race could make a
big difference as Republican primary
voters there give him a sky-high 86
percent approval rating Brett Peter
thank you